you make some good friends at least
yeah i got one yeah but it's like
complicated oh
well are you friends or are you
special kind of friend both okay yeah
okay what are you in love with him or
something it hurts
oh ooh little plot twist okay
no room for heteronormativity in here
so what i don't know i don't know what
it is
yeah it's not like great right now
not exactly like in the best place
i came here so i wouldn't have to think
about it
i understood
what the the
[Applause]
is
[Music]
don't forget
he's
hey anna someone i want you to meet
hi i'm joel
i know you like it
did y'all make these our are friended
i mean are you guys gonna go out oh
anna's always trying to put makeup on me
it's so awkward
i remember walking out of sears with
my first pair of heels in my backpack
cute and
my heart was racing
and i got home i went straight to my
room locked the door
put them on and
[Music]
it just felt like i was
collecting herbs or
making potions in order to up my mana
you know
like it started with bed and then it was
clothes and then it was
makeup and eventually hormones
um i just kind of kept
leveling up so
what level are you at now i don't know
but i definitely haven't reached my full
power
but you date guys right
date isn't really the right word what
she means to say is that she's a
you what it's not an insult i mean
but you normally hook up with guys
yeah but my relationship to men
is weird like how
in my head it's like
if i can conquer men then i can conquer
femininity
why do you need a guy to make you feel
more feminine
hmm
we'll circle back to that one
so have you i mean what
conquered femininity
i don't know but it's not like i even
want to conquer it it's like i want to
obliterate it
and then move on to the next level
from the next thing level up
level up yeah i don't really know what
that
means or looks like but
i want it awareness is infinite
okay look at me
yeah you look adorable
[Music]
stuff
you